early versions of the p47 did suffer
from poor climb and turning performance
that massive engine added a great deal
of weight and by virtue of the large
fuselage needed to hold it a great deal
of parasitic drag too in order to climb
or turn the engine and wings need to
provide the force necessary to lift the
plane to higher altitude or shift its
direction these characteristics did not
affect the P 47's roll rate however
where it excelled thanks to a fantastic
Aeron control however in a dog fight
being outturn or out climbed was a death
sentence climb rates were improved for
the p47d 22 and onward with the addition
of a new larger propeller a 4 M diameter
propeller nicknamed the paddle prop is
had a longer cord and distinctive cuffs
which helped Channel more air into the
engine